[Music]
[Applause]
he's jason clark great actor zero dark
30. he was the star of that or one of
the stars and he portrays jerry west in
the new hbo series about the showtime
lakers called winning time jason clark
joining us on the program what do people
say when they see you on the street
uh it's funny it depends where i am like
when i come in when i fly into the
airport say a lot of the guys wreck
servicemen there and they've seen zero
dark 30. so they're always very
respectful and i find that
you know with every
you know
police officers from chicago that are in
chicago code they're always lovely to me
whenever i go there and you know on the
whole
other than that a lot of the general
public that don't really understand or
know that i'm australian or they don't
recognize me or when somebody do it kind
of like okay they're very nice though
but i asked keith urban about this that
he's got that australian accent he's
from australia
but i didn't realize it until you talk
to him and you're like damn it just is
so strange and he goes no it's not he
goes you know the beatles were from
england and yeah you know when they sang
nobody said oh they sound like they're
from england how do you how do you make
that transition from that accent to just
sounding like you're american
you have to it's like you know it's kind
of it's a blessing actually in my mind
because it makes you not lazy because
you have to do a different accent
australia the australian accent is a
very is a very you know way back in the
mouth and you know how are you doing you
know you can't really understand you
know it speaks like that but it but it
makes you do the work dan you know and
that's um you know i find a person's
voice or a person's accent you know
where they speak from
gives a lot of indication of who they
are and what they're about you know and
how they grew up for you know for jerry
west i did you know the governor of west
virginia
but like his accent is stronger than
jerry's say so i will use that to warm
up and and get my muscles going bigger
and then i'll come back to jerry's as
well to tone it down a bit you know
did you meet jerry west before playing
jerry west
no i met him on your show watching a lot
of stuff a lot of your interviews and
listening to a lot of actually listen to
a lot of your stuff dude i was very
excited to talk to you
um and i thought about contacting you
before we were shooting but um you know
i knew that you and jerry were friends
and i
you know i didn't want to intrude on him
and his and his business
um more than i have
so
you know it was it was through you know
your westwood which i loved was three
injuries with jerry over the years
you know which i listened to of you know
we start early on you know but now i use
a lot of clear pictures of where he's at
in 2016.
there was a vocal it was an interview
that you did i listened to a lot for his
accent and the way he spoke and then you
know and westwood which i loved and the
final interviews you did with him at the
end beautiful really beautiful
what are you trying to capture with
jerry
i guess i can it's a i guess in a funny
way i'm doing my own personal version of
west on west an exploration
of
of you know this man this logo this icon
this this little boy from west virginia
this um
this older man who
you know
lost so many people including kobe
recently and that and he's and a man who
you know
the thing i loved about his book dan was
he kicked it off with this is this is my
exploration of me you know and then i
and then you'd hear his son ryan read it
which it was really beautiful
and that you still see a man trying to
understand himself and life and things
in it and that's what it is for me as
well to represent
who he was at this particular time when
we kick it off in 79 who the writers are
writing
and then give some kind of essence of
you know the heart of what it is like to
be
you know at jerry west and as an athlete
i was struck by
the way he talked about his issues and
his problems and and it wasn't like i'm
going to sum it up or i'm going to
everything's solved he's an ongoing
thing as we all are and i think we all
should be open about and about as we go
through life and and that's what i'm
doing you know this is no end result or
this is no definitive version i think
i'm the only person to play jerry west
at this point am i i'm not sure probably
so
probably so yeah but i i was wondering
about as i watched the first episode
you're capturing somebody who was in
constant kind of conflict with what he
was who he is
you know he he didn't win it eats away
at him he was mvp but lost the nba
finals you know now
jerry buss is talking about drafting
magic johnson and jerry doesn't want
magic and he wants sydney moncrief like
he's so combustible even the scene when
he's playing golf and he breaks the you
know you break the golf club there like
everything about him is
it it's so intense like how do you tap
into
what is that that i'm trying to kind of
unveil what is it i think it's like i
care so effing much yeah
you know and he talks about that and
i've had my own struggles with that
you know with this the business that i'm
in and your loves you know when you love
big
of course you're gonna get hurt it takes
you a long time to understand that
that's okay though as well
because it's just
you know he
you know and i can relate to that he
talks about it a lot i care so epic much
and even at times he tips over until he
thinks other people don't care as much
which is a weird judgment as well and
then it
it leads to a lot of combustibility but
he talked about that with me a couple of
times where he couldn't even watch the
games yeah he had to drive around los
angeles during games
that he
slept with a shotgun under his mattress
because he was going to kill his dad if
his dad abused his mom again
i i just
i can't imagine
what must like he hated losing i don't
think he loved winning he just hated
losing so much
yeah and you know and i'm he's one of my
favorite people that i've been around
but
i didn't play against him i wasn't
trying to be a gm when he was being a g
like all the things where you go man i
don't want to compete with him and even
now you're competing with
what our image is of jerry west
yeah it's funny dan
that was interviewed in 2016 where he
was at the uh he was at the um the
golden state and he's talking about he
didn't like uh
you know these players hugging each
other and swapping jerseys and all that
you guys are talking about that and i
was actually at the lakers when they
played the pelicans the other night you
know i'm just i just sat down with john
riley
and um and the first thing i saw and i
noticed rather than wow i'm here on
court so i was like oh those two players
are hugging each other they're on
opposite teams and they're they're
giving each other a hug jerry would hate
that what's going on here you know what
i mean that's not the thing you kick off
this you guys are on a losing streak
this is going to get
you know um
yeah it's a funny way there's a you know
there's a couple things i've loved
understanding basketball or beginning to
and and going into it you know and i've
loved talking to guys like you
because there seems to be such a wealth
of knowledge and preparedness with the
interviewers like everyone we've talked
on the sports side of it
you know this is not too disrespected on
the film stuff but there's just a deeper
understanding
of discussing it and thinking about it
and allowing it to be and i guess it's
more you know it's more obvious black
and white than sports say with an
interpretive art we're talking to jason
clark he plays jerry west in the new hbo
series about the showtime lakers
you bring up a great point or a great
point is brought up to you about
walking like an athlete
and you can see people
and you know they were an athlete or
they are an athlete and when jerry still
walks in
he still looks like
that that was that's a star that that
that's an athlete he has the long arms
it was just there's a presence about him
that feels almost a throwback in
hollywood where you're back to the black
and white era and uh he just looks like
a leading man
jerry's ca i mean yeah jerry many people
forget jerry's conducted his life
in front of people since high school
since that game in whisper you know you
say arguably that big game
he's conducted himself in front of
people for a long long long time
and um
and he carries himself in a certain way
you know absolutely does he still train
does he still does he still exercise
he golf so i know that
he plays gin but he's one of those guys
that he always looks like he came out of
a catalog
yeah he looks like he looks after
himself he eats well you know yeah and
um takes care of himself without being
too
it's like joe dimaggio was still alive
you know that that you know that
presence that they when they and he
dresses well though i know how he
dresses no he's right out of gq he's
right out of a catalog
but but you do know when like there's
certain actors and you've been there in
the room and you go oh damn like
somebody walks in and you go oh what
when i when i met michael douglas i was
like oh my god that's a movie star when
when he walked in it's fascinating isn't
it you know one of the things was heath
ledger i knew heath many many years ago
and and heath always had something about
him that was
you know quite expensive quite
extraordinary he knew that
you know
something gravity and the camera
gravitates to him people gravitated to
him clint eastwood when we met him a
couple of years ago like
we're all nervous we're like there's
clinton
there's clint eastwood and i walked over
to him i said hi clint i'm dan patrick
goes yeah you are
yeah you
and
that that was it
but he's got it sir he's got an amazing
one
i remember that i love i don't think it
was one of my favorite movies let's see
where he's filling up the give him the
rifle you know and the bullets too yeah
it was funny the other thing that was
interesting was
i really learned to hear jerry swear on
your show too and some of the outtakes
and some of the leadings i heard the
first bits of that
which was a real another key into
you know the public jerry and the
private jerry and the relaxed jerry or
the on jerry you know
and um it's jarring
it was jarring for me when i heard
you're here
just like yes
yes i can hear him in there now i'm
getting you know because he is he's you
know and he has to conduct himself as
well when you're talking to you know
when you're when you're caught side of
the game or what everyone's watching
what you know you said
he's not doing that but like
i don't think you're saying anymore
because you're on camera and it's
getting so close so but you know it was
fun because i swear a bit in there you
know i go over the top as well you know
it's with tv and we're
we're we're we're reinforcing the legend
as well as you know the reality yeah and
um but it was uh you know it was it was
good to hear that and then there was
there was there was another guy that
worked with him that said yeah you know
you know jerry swears law
jace congratulations great to talk to
you and thank you mate and good luck
with this and i'm going to show you
something before you go though because
i've watched your show because i've been
listening to it i put it on my ipod and
listened to it all the time did that
that's how i warm up your 2016 interview
for starters going over i warm up by
listening to that again and again and
again and again and again but um look at
this dude
[Laughter]
so that's the jerry west bobble head is
it good is it good jerry yeah am i doing
good am i doing okay is he gonna like me
no no no no no he's not
yeah i are you curious what jerry thinks
of you playing jerry
you know i am
i am of course i am of course i care i
deeply care you know i understand that
you know you got children you've got to
do it's a different time now and period
and that there's a lot of concerns and
it's yourself and
you know
that it's not something that maybe he's
welcoming of and everything and
and um if i ever do meet someone you
know i've reached out of courtesy but i
i don't want to talk about it or i'd
love to have a glass of wine with them
and discuss art you know all the things
or the history we have a lot of similar
interests and um and and so you know i
would
um you know i get it but at the same
time you're jerry west i guess you've
got to expect that in your heart that
somebody sometimes is going to play you
and um
and so long as they're not disrespectful
and so long as they're you know they're
not libelous
you know
it's going to happen when you've done
what the man's done so
i'd be more than happy to have a glass
of burgundy and not even bring it up
thank you jason good luck we appreciate
you joining us
cheers mike
that's uh jason clark he plays jerry
west it's the hbo series